>> Peter Vankevich: Boy,
we've had a wonderful
turnout here today.
So, just want to
introduce Ron Charles.
He's book critic at
The Washington Post,
but I have a personal
observation
that there is no better friend
of the National Book
Festival outside
of the Library of
Congress than Ron.
I mean, he's-- we've been
together, how many years, Ron?
And he is just-- he's a
cheerleader for us in addition
to all his great observations
about the writers
and everything.
So we're always glad
to see you in fiction.
>> Ron Charles: Thank you
very much, [inaudible].
>> All right, and just stay
seated, go ahead and start.
OK.
>> Ron Charles: Thank you.
>> Peter Vankevich: All right.
Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: I
did not expect that.
Thank you very much.
It's very kind of you.
First, a word of thanks to our
co-chairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein, and the other
generous sponsors who've made
this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
there's a note in your program.
We'll have time after this
conversation for your questions
and I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
through the microphone, you will
be included in the videotape
of this event and become a part
of the permanent
collection of the library.
So you're in like a witness
relocation program or something.
Just stay in your seat OK.
My guest today is Jennifer Egan.
She's the author of several
books including "Look at Me"
and "A Visit from the
Goon Squad", and--
which is a widely
inventive novel
which won the 2011
Pulitzer Prize.
Also a journalist--
[ Applause ]
-- also a journalist,
she's written frequently
for The New York Times
Magazine and her new novel,
"Manhattan Beach", was
published last fall.
Let's start with that moment.
After the success of "A
Visit from the Goon Squad",
Pulitzer Prize, rave reviews,
how do you summon the courage
to write something else?
>> Jennifer Egan: Well, I
wish we're only a moment
when I have to contemplate that.
It was many moments
drawn together.
I think initially, I
didn't feel too intimated
because I thought
reasonably, look,
I didn't promise everyone
would love everything I do.
I just got lucky that time
and now I'm proceeding.
And for about a year of
working in the first draft
that I felt excited by what I
was doing and good about it.
But then I began to feel how
hard it was going to be to make
"Manhattan Beach"
work and I began
to really recognize how far
outside my comfort zone I had
moved with that book.
Not really because it's
not structurally wacky
like "Goon Squad" is.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: But more
because since I don't
really write about myself
or people I know ever,
the real points of contact
between my life and my work
are always times and places
that I remember, and
I hadn't realized
that those are actually kind
of essential to what I'm doing.
But in "Manhattan Beach", I
moved outside of my lifetime
and I found that I had really
no times in places to pull
from in my memory at all.
And, I felt really
unqualified to do that.
And I thought it was
going to be a disaster.
And at that point,
I freaked out.
I really thought, wow,
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I'm writing
a disastrous book, you know,
after having this other
one turn out so well.
What should I do?
I thought about abandoning it.
And I really was pretty
serious about that.
I thought, OK, you have
permission to leave
that book aside but then
the question was, OK,
so what do I want to do?
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: And the
answer was I wanted to do this.
I wanted to stick with
"Manhattan Beach", that was sort
of where my mind was going.
So I hang in there.
>> Ron Charles: And this is
the first historical novel
you'd written?
>> Jennifer Egan: Yes.
Well, the first one takes place
outside of my lifetime, yes.
>> Ron Charles: Right, 50 years.
This is your parents' lifetime?
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Why 50 years?
Why didn't you write for the
12th century, the 17th century?
>> Jennifer Egan:
Well, don't tempt me.
I think really it was
specifically New York during
World War II that interested me.
So even though it was not a time
and a place from my own memory,
it was a time and a
place specifically
that drew me into this material.
I wanted to know what New
York was like during the war,
what it felt like to be there
and also just in
America generally.
I had kind of-- I had
notions about the way
that the country
pulled together.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: The way
that women were invited
to do things they've been
told they couldn't do.
You know, various sort of almost
cliched ideas, but I wanted
to really know what
it felt like.
And that may have started with
9/11 and having been living
in New York when that happened
and experienced the sort
of transformation of my
landscape into a kind
of war zone overnight.
That may have been
it, I don't know.
>> Ron Charles: And how did
you go about that research?
I mean, some of the
people were still alive.
>> Jennifer Egan: Well, they--
when I first started having
these inclinations toward New
York during World War II,
it was actually about 2005.
So I had-- I was working on
"The Keep", I wasn't even--
I hadn't even started "A Visit
from the Goon Squad" yet.
And in a way, that
timing was really lucky
because I got involved in
interviewing a lot of people
in those years between 2005 and
2010 who were in their 80s then.
So, I collaborated an
oral history project
with the Brooklyn Navy Yard and
the Brooklyn Historical Society.
And our goal was to interview
everyone we could find
who had worked at the navy yard.
And I was especially
interested in women
who had worked there during
the war and I was lucky enough
to be present for-and to help
interview about 20 ladies.
>> Ron Charles: Who had this
experience or something like it?
>> Jennifer Egan: Yes, who did
all kinds of things at the yard,
ranging from office work to
actual welding and riveting.
These were amazing
stories to hear.
>> Ron Charles: I'm sure.
>> Jennifer Egan: And they've
impacted the story that I ended
up writing fairly directly not
in that I used anyone
that I had met.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: Because,
again, that's something I--
not only don't do,
but I sort of can't.
I'm really bad at that.
But the little details that they
gave me and coupled with a lot
of reading that I did over the
same period, in a certain way,
it was almost like I amassed a
sort of alternate memory bank--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- to
give me something to draw
from since I didn't
have my own memories.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
Can you tell us about a
moment of particular discovery
that was surprising
or delightful?
>> Jennifer Egan: Well,
I'm always drawn to this--
I don't know exactly-- this is--
it wasn't really a discovery
about the period but I want to
mention a woman whose collection
of letters was very,
very important to me,
her name was Lucille
Kolkin and she
and her husband, Al Kolkin, met.
They both worked
at the Navy Yard.
He was a machinist and
she was a ship fitter.
And they had a kind
of Navy Yard romance
and they married precipitously.
And in one of her
letters, she referred to it
as from maidenhood to
marriage in three easy months.
So, that she was
crazy in love with Al
and he then joined the navy
and went to booth camp.
And so she wrote him these
wonderful letters every day
that were fantastic
from my point of view
because she wrote a lot about
her specific work at the yard
since he knew what
she was talking about.
And she also, you know,
just flirted with him
and told him all kinds
of little anecdotes.
She was very interested
in unionization.
She talked about race.
She really talked about all the
things you hope someone will
talk about--
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, it's a
historian's dream, isn't it?
>> Jennifer Egan: -- from
that particular time, exactly.
And then there was one letter
when she fantasized about--
and she had had a dream
that they had had a son
and that Al was changing the
baby's diaper and she said, oh,
butch, that's what
she call them,
what will our lives be like?
You know, where will we live?
What-- How many children
will we have?
And I thought, yeah, I wondered
what will happen to Lucy.
And then I thought, wait
a minute, that was 1944,
there are answers
to these questions.
So I, of course, did what we
all do when we have a question,
I walked directly to the
nearest computer terminal
and I Googled her and within 30
seconds of reading this dream
in her handwriting, I
was reading her obituary.
>> Ron Charles: Oh my gosh.
>> Jennifer Egan: And
it was so shocking.
It was-- It felt like a mind
should not be able to do both
of those things in
that amount of time.
>> Ron Charles: Were you close
or had she died long before?
>> Jennifer Egan: No, she had
just died a few years before.
>> Ron Charles: Oh my gosh.
>> Jennifer Egan: And she had
actually lived down the street
from where I had lived at
the time that she died.
She had had two daughters
and it was over.
And, I returned to
the letters and I felt
so strange reading
them at first.
I felt like I knew more than
I should be allowed to know.
And she was kind of prattling
about getting a sunburn
at Coney Island and putting
bicarbonate of soda on it.
I was thinking I know something
terrible that you don't know,
your life is going to end.
So it was very strange but,
ultimately, I kind of forgot
about it and got back
into her wonderful voice.
And then she went and joined
Al and so the letters ended.
She was-- They were together.
And I found that I
really missed her.
I felt like I had lost a pal
that I was used to hanging
out with a couple
of times a week
at the Brooklyn Historical
Society.
So I wrote an essay
called "Reading Lucy",
which was about the
uncanny power of letters
to make someone feel alive.
And I published in a
little collection of book--
of essays about Brooklyn
by various writers.
And about three months later
on my public email address,
I got an email and
the subject line was,
I am Lucille's daughter.
>> Ron Charles: Oh.
>> Jennifer Egan: Incredible.
So, she had two daughters as
I had learned in the obituary.
Judy and Marj and all of-- they
and their families and I and Al
who was then in his
80s all took a tour
of the Navy Yard together.
>> Ron Charles: That's great.
>> Jennifer Egan: I mean,
you can't make this stuff up.
I mean, these were the kinds
of adventures I was having.
This was all before "Goon
Squad" even came out.
>> Ron Charles: Wow.
>> Jennifer Egan: So-- And I'm
in touch with them to this day.
>> Ron Charles: That's so sweet.
>> Jennifer Egan: I accompanied
Al with his walker back
into the machine shop
which was now empty,
but there were still
a lot of the war left
at the Navy Yard back in 2008
and I could hardly look at Al.
I knew way too much
about Al [laughter].
And I mean, these lines
from her letters would float
through my head like, just
a few more little kisses
and an incy wincy
pinch on the ass end.
I'm like--
>> Ron Charles: That's
so romantic.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- yeah.
Well, they were working
at a ship yard.
And so, anyway, Al actually
only passed away two years ago
in '98, and we ended
up interviewing him
for the oral history project.
It was really-- it
enriched my life in such a--
>> Ron Charles: Great.
>> Jennifer Egan: --
deep way, this research.
>> Ron Charles: That's amazing.
>> Jennifer Egan: It
stopped feeling like research
and it just felt like living.
>> Ron Charles: Friends,
that's great.
It seemed to me that if
you go back 300 years,
you could get all
kinds of stuff wrong
and hardly anybody would know.
I mean, some scholars
would know.
But if you go back 50, 60 years,
there are a lot of readers
out there who will
know and all of the--
it seems to me there
are infinite number
of things to get wrong.
>> Jennifer Egan: I'm
finding that [laughter].
>> Ron Charles: So
how do you check?
How do you do that sort
of historical checking?
>> Jennifer Egan: You know,
readers are kind
enough to share--
>> Ron Charles: Oh--
>> Jennifer Egan: --
their discoveries.
>> Ron Charles: --
that's too late.
That's too late.
>> Jennifer Egan: No, it isn't.
Not if you keep going
into more printings.
No, I've fixed a lot.
It's interesting-- there's a
lot of technology in the book
because there is so much
about people at work.
So there is--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- people
who work at the Navy Yard.
They're deep sea divers.
There's a lot of mob activity.
And there's-- you know,
there's a lot of ship building.
So interestingly, in those
areas where I had to know a lot,
I tended to get things right
because I had worked so hard
to understand the technology--
>> Ron Charles: Research thing.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- correctly.
>> Ron Charles: It was the
casual references that--
>> Jennifer Egan: And I
had people to help me.
So I had an expert usually
in each of those fields,
but it was other things that I
didn't know and it's amazing,
people catch everything.
You know, it turns out the
Second Avenue elevated trucks
were dismantled the year before
I had them casting a shadow
on my characters [laughter].
So there are a lot-- there
were a lot of things like that.
Oh, and actually, there was
kind of a big one which is
that I have a deacon in the
novel who does various things.
And it turns out that there
was no really official deacon
in the Catholic Church
at that time,
so that definitely
had to be fixed.
>> Ron Charles: Wow.
>> Jennifer Egan: There are
still some outstanding errors
that I've just heard about
that I have to still fix,
apparently there were
no funerals on Sunday
in the Catholic Church and I
have my funeral on a Sunday.
So--
>> Ron Charles: My gosh.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- yeah.
So it's ongoing, I kind
of love having the chance
to correct these things--
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- overtime.
>> Ron Charles: And paperback
reprints and things like that.
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Or the e-book.
>> Jennifer Egan: Just every
time I keep putting them in
and if there's ever a
chance they run them
through with the next iteration.
>> Ron Charles: Nice, nice.
I was talking to Deborah
Harkness, a historical novelist,
and she was talking about
how hard it is to leave stuff
out because you find out so much
and it's so interesting to you.
How do you keep the
book from reading
like a big research project?
>> Jennifer Egan: Well,
I hope I achieved that.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: I think--
I mean, it's interesting,
I always thought
the reason put--
people put too much in was
that they were showing off.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: I
think the real danger is
that I found I was so in love--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- with
those technical details
that I was a bad judge of how
much other people might love
to know about some
of these things.
I think for me, what really
helped was just multiple
readers, layers of readers
who said to me, you know,
I'm going to sleep here
in chapter whatever.
So, no, that is really,
really a danger.
The other thing is
that it's, you know,
action and people are the
only things we're ever really
reading for.
You know, no one
is reading to learn
about how people
adjusted their air supply
in a Mark V diving suit.
You can--
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan:
-- there are lots
of sources for that information.
So, I guess one standard I tried
to set with myself is just do,
is this-- I mean, is
this part of action,
is this actually necessary, is
something really happening here.
And if you revise enough,
a lot of that extraneous
stuff falls away.
>> Ron Charles: Just falls away.
Now, this-- Anna Kerrigan is
your wonderful protagonist here.
She doesn't call
herself a feminist,
probably doesn't even think
of herself as a feminist.
>> Jennifer Egan:
I'm not sure that--
I don't even know
if that word was--
I had never encountered in my--
>> Ron Charles: Exactly.
>> Jennifer Egan: --
research from that time.
>> Ron Charles: But
she clearly is, right?
>> Jennifer Egan: I mean, she
believes that she should be able
to do what a man can do and --
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- as
far as I'm concerned,
anyone who believes
that is a feminist.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: Because that's
what the word means, really.
And this tells about
this job I'd never heard
of that she takes on
and how dangerous it is.
How did you discover that?
>> Jennifer Egan: Well, Anna--
so there are three protagonists
in the book and Anna is a
19-year-old, I want to say girl,
but really she's an
adult and at that time,
I think a 19-year-old was
something closer to an adult.
She begins doing industrial work
at the Navy Yard as
so many women did.
Although her work is
actually sort of dull,
she's measuring small parts.
She sees someone in
a Mark V diving suit,
which is the iconic sort of
suit that we would all picture,
I think, although that's
not really current anymore.
And she becomes fixated
on the idea of diving.
In a way, it happened very
similarly for me what--
the fixation I'm wanting
to write about diving.
I was researching the
Brooklyn Navy Yard
and I found a little
reminiscence in a naval journal
by a guy who had been a
civilian diver at the yard.
And he talked about how the--
you know, the air supply
was manually produced,
so think about that, you know,
you're 30 feet underwater
and two guys going like this,
are all that is providing
oxygen to you.
>> Ron Charles: And you're in
like what we would think of more
of the space suit, right?
>> Jennifer Egan: It looks very
much like a space suit, yeah.
It's the spherical
hat as they call it,
the very heavy rubberized
canvas,
the lead boots, it
weighs 200 pounds.
First-- Looking at a
photograph of this gentleman
in that outfit, I felt a kind
of thrill that I have learned
to watch very closely, because
it means not that I'm going
to dive, which I
have never done and--
>> Ron Charles: You've
never been scuba diving.
>> Jennifer Egan:
-- afraid to do.
No, but that this is sort of a
portal into something fictional.
And it just-- it-- my
fascination with it only grew
as I fell in with a bunch
of army diving veterans.
Early on, again, this is
before " Goon Squad" came out,
I went to a reunion in Virginia
of this army diving
veterans organization.
They meet every other
year, they're wonderful.
Most of them are Vietnam vets.
There were a couple
from the Korean War
and there was actually one
diver there from World War II.
He dove in Cherbourg and the
Harbour, helping to clear
out debris that the
Germans exploded there,
a guy named Jim Kennedy.
Anyway, I attended this
and interviewed a lot
of these people which was really
fun and one of the attractions
of this reunion is
that anyone who wants
to can wear the old
equipment and dive in a tank.
And most of even-- oddly,
this Mark V was current
into the Vietnam War
so it actually had a
very long period of--
>> Ron Charles: This 200-pound--
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: -- thing?
>> Jennifer Egan: Yes.
And many, and even people--
so another person who helped me
a lot was the first female army
diver, a woman named
Andrea Motley Crabtree,
who was a marvelous human being.
And she even wore and
trained the Mark V
and she didn't dive
until the '80s.
So it's still used
in various ways.
Anyway, I was dressed
in it, my sources,
my two wonderful diving sources
who both dove during the Vietnam
War dressed me in the Mark V,
needless to say, I did not
dive, because that would be--
had been surely the end of me.
But, I watched people
dive in the tank
in that old equipment
which was amazing.
>> Ron Charles: Gosh.
>> Jennifer Egan: Anyway, I--
it became a tremendously
important part of the book
and also a real source of sort
of mystery and excitement for me
in the writing process.
>> Ron Charles: It's very
exciting in the book too.
I mean, when you realize how
dangerous it is, it's dark.
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Explain
to me a little bit more
about what they're-- what
are they doing down there?
>> Jennifer Egan:
Well, civilian divers
at the Brooklyn Navy
Yard were both patching
and repairing ships
from underneath
because there were
only six dry docks even
in that huge ship yard, so a lot
of things could be done while
in the water, it was a big deal
to bring a ship into
the dry dock.
A lot of times also, what they
were doing was just examining
the ships to see what
exactly was wrong.
They also did a lot of salvage
works that they brought things
up from the bottom of the
bay, of Wallabout Bay,
which is where the Navy Yard--
the Brooklyn Navy Yard is right
on the east river in New York.
And so they did a lot of
that, they did various things.
Basically, they're
underwater engineers.
And another thing that
civilian divers did that's kind
of amazing in New York
was that the SS Normandie,
which was a French ocean liner
that we seized when France fell
to the Nazis, was docked
alongside Manhattan
on the Hudson River
and it caught fire.
And so the firefighters
poured water
in it-- into it and it sank.
So it was a bit of
a screw up really
on the firefighters' part and--
which was following a screw
up on the part of the people
who were trying to convert
it into a troop ship.
Anyway, there were--
sabotage was suspected
but it wasn't that, it
was just human error.
Anyway, here is this huge
ocean liner lying at the bottom
of the Hudson River
and a civilian diving program
was initiated to raise the ship,
which consists of making
it airtight, first of all,
then pumping out all the
water, it floats to the top.
They then brought it to the
Brooklyn Navy Yard to turn it
into a troop ship at
which point they learned
that it was too damaged for
them to actually do that.
But, basically, New York was
crawling with civilian divers.
And it was a very
little documented program
which worked very
well for my purposes,
because while no women dove
for the navy until the '70s
and the army until the
'80s, no one really knows
who these civilian divers
were, so that gave me my window
of opportunity to get Anna,
one of my protagonists,
underwater in a diving suit.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
Now, there is this whole
gangster plot running
through the novel, too.
That must have been fun.
>> Jennifer Egan: It
was amazingly fun.
>> Ron Charles: You've got
this kind of noir tone,
you've got cliffhanger endings,
well-dressed killers say things
like, one more word like that
and I'll toss you off the
pier myself and you'll tell it
to the fishes [laughter].
What was that like to sort
of mimic and even sometimes,
I think, parody those old
gangster films or stories?
>> Jennifer Egan: It
was incredibly fun.
I mean, crime is just
an inherently rich realm
for the fiction writer,
you know,
the stakes are immediately high.
There is the sense of danger.
And so that automatically
is of interest.
My grandfather was a cop in
Chicago on the south side
and ultimately became
a commander.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Egan: So I
would listen to his stories
when I was a little girl.
And so I think that kind of
adds to my love of that stuff.
>> Ron Charles: And
that was in the '30s?
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: So this
was some great times--
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: -- in Chicago.
>> Jennifer Egan:
Oh yes [laughter].
Yes, there's a famous
anecdote my uncle tells,
where my grandfather
was with his Fedora.
He was a very sharp
dresser and, in fact,
he was one of Truman's
bodyguards whenever he would
come to Chicago.
There are great pictures of
Truman and my grandfather
and my grandfather's partner
all in their Fedoras, amazing.
>> Ron Charles: That's great.
>> Jennifer Egan: But
my grandfather was sort
of watching people walk
by on the street
looking kind of dower.
And my uncle said, "What
are you doing, dad?"
And he said, "Trying to
separate the good guys
from the bad guys [laughter]."
So I guess I grew up
hearing stuff like that.
But in fact, the real reason
that I ended up writing so much
about gangsters in
this book was suggested
by the research I was doing
before I had a plot or anything
like it back in 2005 to 2010.
Because one thing I found in
not just the conversations
with people who worked
at the Navy Yard,
but also just elderly New
Yorkers with good memories.
I interviewed anyone I
could find who can talk
about New York, you know,
in the '30s and '40s.
A lot of people seem
to encounter gangsters
in the course of
their normal lives.
To a degree, that seems
very odd to us now.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Egan: I
think, certainly to me.
>> Ron Charles: It's
becoming more normal now.
>> Jennifer Egan:
Yes, [laughter].
You might say so.
But-- So, for example, there
was a guy that I interviewed
who was part of a very wealthy
Jewish manufacturing family
and they lived in a
fancy apartment building
that had a name on Central Park.
And Frank Costello, a known--
a very famous crime boss lived
in the apartment building also.
So, my source was
mentioning, well, we got--
there was a movie star,
there were these bankers,
there was Frank Costello,
he was a gangster.
And I was picturing, you know,
a co-op board in New York now,
you know, contemplating someone
whose job title basically
was gangster.
I don't think that that person
would end up in the building.
So-- But this would
come up again and again.
You know, people
who were musicians,
we talk about playing
at gangster clubs.
>> Ron Charles: Wow.
>> Jennifer Egan:
There were many--
there was a lot of
talk of gangsters.
And, as I did more research,
I learned that, of course,
that had to do with
prohibition and the fact
that the organized
crime got organized
to run the liquor
business for a country
that still wanted to drink.
And therefore, it became--
they became sort of folded--
so-called gangsters became
folded into mainstream life
in a way that seems
very odd to us now.
And that really held on even
after prohibition, of course,
that ended in '33, it was
still true in the '40s.
>> Ron Charles: That is amazing.
>> Jennifer Egan:
So, it seemed to come
about really more that way.
But I had a ball writing about--
>> Ron Charles: I have that.
>> Jennifer Egan: --
Dexter Styles, my--
well, actually, in a way,
the two male protagonists
are Dexter Styles
who was clearly a gangster and
a sort of night club impresario.
And then Eddie Kerrigan, who's
Anna's father, who comes--
who's a part of a sort of
different criminal realm
which is the Irish Waterfront
which was a very corrupt area.
And that corruption was
immortalized in the movie
"On the Waterfront", which
is derived from a series
of newspaper exposes of the
corrupt Irish Waterfront.
The ethnicity was kind
of removed for the film,
but it really was this
very sort of clannishly,
Irish and Irish-American bunch
of very corrupt union bosses
who did not look out for the
interest of their membership.
And were incredibly very
capricious about who worked
and who didn't, and usually the
ones who worked were the ones
who were giving them kickbacks.
So Eddie Kerrigan, Anna's
father, is part of that world
which was-- and then
Dexter Styles is more part
of what was known
as the syndicate
which had a more
Italian feeling,
although in no way
were they all Italian.
And in fact, you
hear funny things
about Irish man calling
themselves, you know,
Genosa and Italian guys
calling themselves O'Brian.
Everyone trying to
fit in with the group
that they are, you know--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- it's the
American reinvention was--
it was going on all
the time there.
>> Ron Charles: Could you
read a passage from that--
>> Jennifer Egan: Sure.
>> Ron Charles: --
part of the novel?
>> Jennifer Egan: So
this is just a little bit
about how Dexter ended
up becoming a gangster.
For Dexter Styles, the existence
of an obscure truth recessed
behind an obvious one,
and emanating through it
allegorically, was mesmerizing.
It was what had first intrigued
him, at age 15, about two men
who came every third
Monday to see his father
and at his Coney
Island restaurant.
Another man came less often,
always in brand-new spats,
a red handkerchief gushing
from his breast pocket.
Dexter's father always
went behind the bar
to pour this man's brandy rather
than have the barkeep do it.
The blank face his pop wore
after these visitations
betrayed humiliation and anger,
and Dexter knew better than
to ask what they meant.
But he was drawn to
the man, a smoldering
of dim feeling behind their
eyes, a heaviness to their hands
when they gave him
a pat or a swat.
He curried their favor,
refilling their glasses,
lingering at their tables when
his father wasn't watching.
They took notice
of him gradually
with a mute animal awareness.
Later, when men who'd fought
the Great War returned,
Dexter recognized, in
their fractured gazes
and somnolent movements,
something of what he'd first
admired in Mr. Q.'s men.
By then, he knew what it
meant, intimacy with violence.
>> Ron Charles: It's nice.
Very nice.
[ Applause ]
I had no idea, the novel --
that you've worked in the
novel for so long that it--
>> Jennifer Egan: Well--
>> Ron Charles: --
predated other novels.
I have yours that I'd read.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- well,
definitely, the research did.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: I didn't
really start writing this
until 2012.
>> Ron Charles: OK.
>> Jennifer Egan: But that
period from 2009 to 2010,
when I was interviewing a
lot of people in their 80s
and those are interviews,
obviously, you can't postpone.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: In fact, Jim
Kennedy, the World War II diver
that I interviewed at
the-- at that reunion,
had wonderful stories to tell
about his time in Cherbourg.
And I asked him if he had
ever met of female diver.
And he said, he had met--
he had dived in Cherbourg
with a female Russian woman.
I mean, obviously,
a female Russian.
And of course, the Russian
woman did everything.
And I felt like there
might be more to the story
than what he was saying
to this large group
of people who are-- of men--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- and
then me all listening to him.
So, we had a plan to
speak again on the phone
and I thought maybe
I would learn more
about the Russian lady.
But Jim Kennedy, in perfect
health in our conversation,
passed away very suddenly
and we've never able
to have that conversation.
So, there was a certain
urgency but, yes, I was working
in "The Keep" and
then on "Goon Squad".
And I would go so far as to say
that my preoccupation with time
in "Goon Squad" to some
degree came from this research
and talking to so many people
toward the ends of their lives.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: But
also that experience
of reading Lucille Kolkin's
letters knowing the end
of her story--
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- I think,
became a kind of technique
that I brought to "Goon Squad".
I wondered how-- if I could
write a whole narrative
in which we more often than
not know the end before we know
the beginning.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: I
think it really came
from that moment in part.
>> Ron Charles: Fascinating.
When you work on a book or
an issue or a story so long,
how do you know when it's done?
>> Jennifer Egan: Well, in
a certain way, it isn't.
I mean, I'm still correcting
mistakes and I can promise you,
if I sat down and read this
book, I would edit heavily.
I know I would.
That's why I'm very
careful not to do that.
>> Ron Charles: So when does
your editor finally just rested
away from you?
>> Jennifer Egan: I mean,
you know, there are various--
and I'm sure just like with
writing for a newspaper, it's--
>> Ron Charles: No,
the deadline comes
and you're done, that's it.
>> Jennifer Egan: Well,
that's kind of the
same thing in a way--
>> Ron Charles: Really?
>> Jennifer Egan: -- in
that, ultimately, if you've--
if you're going to
publish at a certain time--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- you have
sets of page proofs but finally,
you have to-- they
have to take them away.
>> Ron Charles: Stop.
>> Jennifer Egan: But in a way,
those are about little
refinements.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: I
mean, as I was working
in the first draft during the
kind of bad year and a half
where I felt really pessimistic.
One of the things that was
troubling me was that I felt
like I couldn't seem to-- I kept
writing and writing but instead
of feeling the sort
of compression
that I'm hoping for was--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- fiction
which really is an
active compression--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: --
at its base, I kept feeling like
things just kept getting bigger.
And that was really a worry.
But it turned out, and part
of that is just the crazy way
that I write first draft by hand
and very blindly, I was just--
I needed to sort of
cast out a very wide net
to find the elements that
I needed for my story.
And then, once I knew where
it was going to end and sort
of what the end would be
by the time I began
the big second draft.
But in terms of, you know,
knowing that every sentence is
right, I got us close to that
as I could that particular
time, but I'm sure
if I read it now, I
would make changes.
>> Ron Charles: Wow, wow.
Who do you read for inspiration?
>> Jennifer Egan: Oh, gosh.
Well, I mean, every book has
its-- has sort of, I find,
a kind of constellation of
books that it's part of.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: And so
for this book, that was kind
of free-ranging base, in a way,
I combined two genres here.
One is the noir, as
you've pointed out.
So, that, obviously, exists
in film but also in a lot
of cheesy detective fiction--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- and some
really good detective fiction.
I mean--
>> Ron Charles: Yes,
a lot of fun ones.
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah,
Raymond Chandler, I think,
was really important for me.
Partly because his protagonist,
Philip Marlowe, is so--
I feel like he just captures
the kind of bleakness and sense
of existential threat in the
noir that's so compelling.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: And then the
other genre that I'm working
with is really the sea story.
And I thought, can
I really do that?
Can I actually fuse these two?
But what I realized is
that actually they
have so much in common.
They're almost identical.
It's just that one is
in the natural world
and one is in urban world.
Their realms were a sense
of existential threat
existed all times.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: And where a
pocket of humanity is surrounded
by a kind of darkness which
in a sea story-- and a threat.
In a sea story, it's
obviously the sea.
And in the noir,
it's urban life.
It's the solitude and
the kind of vague menace
that we associate or that
that genre associates
with an urban landscape.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: So, I read
a lot in both of these genres.
I revisited "Moby-Dick"
which I absolutely--
>> Ron Charles: It's
really good, isn't it?
>> Jennifer Egan: It is amazing.
>> Ron Charles: I know, I wish
people would read it again.
>> Jennifer Egan: And the
whale parts are great.
>> Ron Charles: Yes,
it's really exciting.
>> Jennifer Egan: I mean, I
never thought I would love
to hear about whale
blubber at that length.
But I did, it was
amazing, amazing.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Egan: And then--
But also like I read a
lot of Patrick O'Brian.
Those are fantastic.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah,
those are fun.
>> Jennifer Egan:
They're like catnip.
>> Ron Charles: Very fun.
>> Jennifer Egan: So lots
of great sea stories
and also great noir.
And a lot of cheesy
detective fiction
that you really couldn't
publish now, it's--
>> Ron Charles: Sexist.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- sexist,
it's racist, it's impossible.
But, for sort of
lingo and elements
of daily life, very useful.
>> Ron Charles: Right,
the tone that you--
that you've get of with
off in the book, yeah.
>> Jennifer Egan: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Very
nice of them.
>> Jennifer Egan:
And I also read a lot
of non-fiction, of course.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: I
mean, and one genre
of that are just
sea survival stories
of which there are many, many.
I mean, so many ships were
torpedoed during World War II.
And there were people
who were torpedoed more
than once in a day.
And, you know, if they wrote--
if they lived to
tell their story,
they did better than
a lot of people.
But these are amazing
stories of incredible heroism
and just bravery, and
strength and leadership.
And then also stories of
absolute disarray and kind
of the way madness can come so
quickly to-- if you don't feel,
you know, the sea
in its enormity--
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan:
-- can really play
in a bad way with,
you know, the mind.
>> Ron Charles: Insanity, yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: And so there
are a lot of those stories, too.
So, all of that.
I think, you know,
at a certain point
when I realize I wasn't
going to be doing a lot
of structural innovation here
which I tried for early on
and discovered was dead on
arrival, I thought, you know,
this is really a story where the
extremes are not going to happen
in the structure
but in the action.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Jennifer Egan: And so, it
was really fun to write about,
you know, a shipwreck, survival
at sea, murders and, you know,
in a way, when I realize that
that was the world of this book,
I thought, it's not surprising
that I'm not using
fragmentation and irony.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Jennifer Egan: I mean,
what place does that have
in a shipwreck, really?
>> Ron Charles: Right, right.
So the whole PowerPoint
shipwreck got taken out.
>> Jennifer Egan: [Laughter]
Well, at the beginning,
I thought I would have a sort of
ironic narrator kind of winking
at the reader about the fact
that we all know this
is a long time ago.
I mean, I have a writing group
that luckily exists to kind
of slap me out of
certain bad ideas.
And the first time I
brought in something
that had that, they
were like, oh.
But it really takes
us out of it.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Egan: And the
second time, they said, "Yeah,
still really not enjoying this."
And then the third time,
they said, "You know,
I find that it makes me really
angry when you do that."
>> Ron Charles: They did?
[Laughter] Just tell
the damn story.
>> Jennifer Egan: This is really
not what I want my readers
to be feeling.
So I think I'm going to
have to move away from that.
>> Ron Charles: Exactly.
Let's hear from some
of your readers.
Would you take some questions?
There are two mics,
one here and one here.
Please just come up to the mic
and Jennifer will point to you.
>> Hi, my favorite work of
yours is "Black Box" actually,
and I just wondered if you'd
ever thought about making
that into a book,
expanding that.
>> Jennifer Egan:
So "Black Box" is--
>> [Inaudible].
>> Jennifer Egan: -- is a
novella that I wrote in tweets
about a female spa--
it's actually a character from
"Goon Squad", a minor character
who is functioning
as a civilian spy.
I hope that will be part of my
next book which I, you know,
may or may not work out.
But if it does, it will
be a sort of a companion
to "Goon Squad" using
various peripheral characters
and hopefully creating
out of that something
that is not just a
tepid echo but something
of interest unto itself.
So we'll see.
>> That's fantastic, it's
compelling read even aside
from the reading it as,
you know, 140 characters--
character, I just loved it.
>> Jennifer Egan:
Thank you so much.
Well, keep your fingers crossed.
>> I also love that story,
because that'd be awesome.
I was going to ask you a
possibly specific question,
but my friend told me that'd
be unfair to the audience so--
>> Jennifer Egan: If you
ask it in veiled terms--
>> Yeah.
>> Jennifer Egan: -- without
using names, I've gotten kind
of good at answering
those questions.
>> Great, I can do that.
So, "A Visit from the
Goon Squad" is one
of my favorite books.
And I know this is sort of
sliding door effects feeling
with the characters, the
choices they make and then kind
of reflecting back on what if,
which kind of scared the hell
out of me when I read it.
It was thrilling as well.
And then, but "Manhattan Beach"
is a little bit different.
But at the end of the book,
maybe I was reflecting for Anna
because she makes a big decision
towards the end of the book.
And I admit, I felt a little bit
cheated by it, when I read it.
I was a little-- I
guess a little upset
because I was feeling, what if,
what if it had gone differently
or she made a different choice.
And I was wondering, freedom
as a writer how you
approach this sort
of the responsibility
to these choices.
>> Jennifer Egan: OK, that's a
good challenge for me to figure
out how to answer this
without you guys knowing what
on earth we're talking about.
But I'm going to answer
generally so that--
which is actually
the true answer
and also doesn't
give anything away.
I think I know what choice
you're talking about.
And what I can say to you
is that my goal always is
to find the thing I
haven't thought of.
So if there are few
obvious courses of action
for a character, those
had better not be any
of the choices that
character makes.
I'm not interested in
something I can think
of as I'm moving toward it.
I want to think of the thing
that didn't pop into my head
until the moment it actually
happened on the page.
Trying to access that kind
of unconscious spontaneity is
the whole reason that I slug
through writing a
1,400-page first draft by hand
for "Manhattan Beach".
It's-- There are
many reasons not
to do that, I can promise you.
One of which is just
having to read it
because my handwriting
is eligible.
The reason to do it is to try to
weave my way among the choices
that I can imagine ahead
of time to find a path
that I hadn't thought of.
The choice that that
character makes is the one
that seems not to exist.
And that's why she doesn't.
Because to me, narratively,
that is what's interesting.
I'm not-- you know, my goal is
never to make a political point
of any sort in my work.
I'm also a journalist and
I feel like that feels
like the more appropriate
realm for that sort
of thing to me with fiction.
My concerns are really
aesthetic, what is going
to be surprising
and what is going
to be unexpected for the reader.
>> Thank you.
>> Jennifer Egan:
You're welcome.
>> So, "Look At Me",
"Visit from Goon Squad"
and "Manhattan Beach" all
feature multiple protagonists
as opposed to just one.
What would you say drove you to
that story telling device over
and over and what advantages
do you think it gives over just
to seeing your limited
narrative?
>> Jennifer Egan: I'm
assuming everyone hear that.
So, why multiple plotlines?
I mean, I think part of it is
just a kind of general wish
to do as much as possible.
I just feel like if-- and
actually that also has a kind
of aesthetic quality to it in
that if I feel like we sort
of get someone if there's
a way in which I feel
like a character is sort
of clear in some way,
my goal is not to
just stay there.
My goal is to now do
something different.
Because if you think about
the complexity of life
and of perception, I mean, all
of us are sitting in this room,
each of us has our
own individual history
and we're here sharing
this moment together
and we're all preceding
it in our own ways,
that's just exponentially
complicated.
My goal as a fiction writer
is to try to suggest as much
of that complication as
I can in a compelling,
hopefully, entertaining way.
So, complication is the goal.
And if I've established
something, my impulse is
to move away from it and try
to bring more into the picture.
And I would have to say,
my models here really are
the 19th century novelists,
who did a tremendous amount
in single books and had a kind
of fluidity that is sometimes
hard for us to even remember.
I think when we think
of those books,
we think of 19th century
fiction as being kind
of conventional but
it's really not.
I mean, they-- or at least not
by our contemporary standards.
They switch points of view.
They move among characters.
They fly through time and that
kind of freedom to do as much
as possible while still
remaining compelling
and hopefully entertaining is
the whole job, in my opinion.
>> Thank you.
>> Jennifer Egan: Here,
let's try this side and then.
>> So you mentioned that
for "Manhattan Beach",
you found a lot of errors
and will fix new printing,
you want to make corrections and
I found that very refreshing.
I was wondering, if you
reprint, do you have any sort
of acknowledgment's page
addressing those changes,
and also, would you consider
making creative changes
with a new round of
printing as opposed
to just technical changes?
>> Jennifer Egan: Well,
I love the thought
of making creative changes.
There is one that I want to
make actually on my list.
But the problem is that
the publisher does not want
to hear that.
And then the danger is
that you start to seem
like you're sort
of-- what's the word,
or being a little
bit unreasonable
or even a little bit unstable.
Like if I suddenly
said, you know,
I don't like the way this
character is coming off,
I need to revisit
this whole thing.
They would say, Jenny, you
should maybe see a therapist.
I mean, this is--
the book is published
and it's time to move on.
But I have-- so that--
but that's one reason I do
not reread my own books.
I mean, first of
all, why would I?
But really, I know that it
would put me in a position
of feeling unhappy
because, surely,
I would find things
that could be better.
That said-- And oh, your
question about what I put
in in acknowledgment stating
the changes, not really,
it's not a newspaper where
I need to acknowledge that--
through an editing
error, through--
you know, through operator error
as which is always the case
when it comes to my fiction.
You know, I got X,
Y, or Z wrong.
I feel more like, no, let's--
let that go and now you're
reading the corrected version,
great.
So-- But this one thing I
might want to change has to do
with shoring up something
that many readers have
questioned whether it was
actually plausible.
And in fact, very much is.
And so I feel like
there may be an easy fix
where I can somehow establish
that at another point.
But I haven't even broached
this with my editor yet.
We'll see.
I'm looking for the
right moment.
>> Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: And
one last question.
>> Do you have any tips,
suggestions, or advice for how
to form like a writing
group with people who kind
of nourish you and look
over your writing and people
who inspire you with
their own writing
and like how would you suggest
forming with that network?
>> Jennifer Egan: That's
such a great question.
I mean, being part of a writing
group has really been a very
important part of
my writing life.
I wrote one book in a vacuum
and it was dead on arrival.
So I don't want to make
that mistake again,
and I had been working at
it for two or three years.
So, I think the key is, first
of all, taking any sort of class
or workshop is-- and
our writing group began
as a paid workshop, actually.
Some of us were paying
one of the people there
to lead the writing group.
And after a few years, she
wanted to bring work in so,
you know, needless to say, it
was time to stop paying her
if we were also going to
be workshopping her work.
I don't think it matters whether
you're working in the same genre
or even whether you necessarily
adore each other's work.
What really matters is a sort
of an agreement on an approach
and a kind of goodwill that
means that everyone that is
on your side, they
genuinely want you to succeed,
which is really important
and can't be taken
for granted but will be honest.
And so, how to find
those people?
There's trial and error.
We've had some chemistry that
didn't work at times and,
you know, we tend to stay small.
There are only six
or seven of us.
One Skypes in from California,
it's only one guy,
I'm sorry to say.
I'd love to have more.
So it's finding that
chemistry, but I think a couple
of things I would say
is we only read aloud.
So there's no homework, there's
no pretending you've read a
little more carefully than
you really had time to.
We have the experience
all at once and I find
that to be a great method.
It's-- We-- There's a natural
triage that happens when you--
all you have time to do
is make a few little notes
about what's really important.
And I find that it's-- you know,
the most important things rise
to the surface and it's less
likely that you get caught
up in the details that
don't really matter.
The, you know, story telling
began as an oral tradition
and there's nothing like
reading your work to a group
to remind you of that.
Sometimes that's a
happy experience.
Sometimes it's really bad.
You know, I'll come
in there with things
that I think are going to
work and I can feel this kind
of lead, glazed feeling coming
over the room and I think,
oh my god, this is--
it's not working at all.
But it's important to know that
and reading aloud is a great
way of finding that out.
But I would-- I think I would
suggest taking a workshop,
taking a class, and
trying little by little
to pull together some people
that can meet and be this kind
of support for each other.
I highly, highly recommend it.
>> Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: And thank you.
Such a pleasure to talk to you.
>> Jennifer Egan: Thank you.
Thank you all.
>> Ron Charles: Great.
>> Jennifer Egan: Fun.